Jennifer Lawrence hints at an actress  she does not get along with in Hollywood  oh hell no  the passengers star was a guest on watch  what happens live with Andy Cohen Monday  where she dished on a certain celebs  about will the lady has different  variations there's a raging lady lady  and red baby waiting but unfortunately  for us Jayla wouldn't reveal who said  lady is like she did reveal which  housewife she'd choose to survive in  space with spoiler it's not Lisa  Vanderpump which housewife would you  like to be stuck with on the Avalon  after waking up too early like the  characters on passengers I've thought  about this a lot okay um and I think  actually as much as I love Lisa  Vanderpump I think Kyle Richards I think  I feel like she's we would balance each  other out a little bit better Wow  apparently survival joy and her BFF  Laura Simpson who played bartender of  the night revealed Jayla doesn't  normally have diva moments but when she  does it'll be like nah right  you